[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
hi there my name is brian wood i'm with
the pr team at wolfram
uh today i'm here with jamie peterson uh
she is from wolf from u
and she's here to talk a bit about some
of the latest events and certification i
personally worked on just a little bit
as well this data science boot camp
really great experience and of course
uh this was the second year we ran data
science boot camp
but the first time we ran it completely
online
since everybody's been working from home
as of late
so our boot camp happened in july and
maybe i'll
um maybe i'll share my screen to show
you what that
uh what that event
give you an idea of what that event was
like uh
so here's our our uh boot camp page it
happened at the end of july
and we ended up with about 40 very
enthusiastic
attendees really with a range of
wolfram language experience many many
were beginners
uh new to an interest in you know maybe
related to their own personal research
and we encouraged them to kind of uh
bring a publicly available data set
or their own private data that they
wanted to
explore as part of this boot camp very
cool so
um so what kinds of projects did you
have coming through there then
just take a look at that refresh myself
on some of these specific projects
boy it really was a wide range we had um
one p i can show one of those
visualizations it might be cool we
actually have this in a blog post so if
you're interested to see more of these
details
i'm sharing some of those here uh but
this is from professor vlacko's project
and um yeah that was funny like the
conclusion he made is that
john reno's uh is easier to read for an
english speaker
uh that was interesting so that was kind
of funny i found some
french wikipedia articles exactly right
pulling the data from wikipedia
um another project was personal fitness
data
and our camper vlad um a cs student
exploring let's see
all right so it looks like yeah the
predicting uh
workout type so that's he's got all
these all these different workout types
um which and actually the thing that i
found impressive about this was the
the accuracy just based on so few
examples
um and and he definitely i know he was
looking for more data he was asking
everyone hey
does anyone else have more data i can
work with so he was he was very
enthusiastic about that
right right and saw some pretty good
results with that um
tim uh is one of our own uh wolfram uh
staff people that that chose to
participate in the boot camp and
uh he was uh building a custom neural
network
to uh to look at word
and sentence sequences um
and this visualization is from his
project here
was this one you had a chance to look at
brian
yeah a little bit um i i some of the
some of the anomalies there i think were
kind of interesting i
i wouldn't have thought about uh what
kinds of letters are
common you know commonly replaced
uh to to make a different word or to you
know re-spell or correct the spelling of
a word
um but some of those that the things you
see listed there like
the fact that j uh is often replaced
with m
you know i i don't know why that's the
case right i i find it really
interesting to
sort of uh and i can only imagine some
of the some of the additional things
that tim may have found in there
right and and the so the motivation for
us pulling these particular projects um
in addition to finding them very
interesting ourselves is that we had our
campers
vote on what their favorite projects
were and these were the projects that
uh got the top votes so and you can i
think you can see why and i hope
everyone takes a look at the blog post
to kind of
uh look a little more into some of these
uh projects
yeah and here's the last one that we
shared this is from
this this was this was a much more
advanced one i thought uh
subspace flow problem a little bit more
technical but uh
made for some some interesting visuals
right
so yeah so what other kinds of events do
you have going on
besides data science boot camp um
we have all kinds of events going on
with wolf from you
in addition and i'd like to if it's okay
i'm going to share my um
my browser again here and i'll show you
our wolfram view page
which will help me navigate through some
of these things here this is our wolfram
u
landing page and the topic areas that we
offer uh training and self-learning
resources but
to see our events we go we go down here
to the bottom and this shows you what's
kind of scheduled right now
so of course technology conference uh
training is one of our
uh one of our upcoming events uh study
groups
is another uh really great opportunity
uh most of these um many are free
online events that happen in study group
right now the linear algebra
is going to be starting mid-october
so very soon coming up and if you're
interested i encourage anyone to go to
that will from you page and check out
the study groups
they meet monday through friday for an
hour with an instructor
and you're reviewing uh short lessons
you're given additional resources
to kind of self study on your own and
then you bring your questions and have
discussion take poll questions take
quizzes
and it really is a fantastic learning
opportunity to really
um build your skills yeah and i've heard
that uh you know it's it's a very
rich environment that is because so many
different people show up to the study
group
you can't beat that price of free so
exactly
exactly and it's very interactive which
is which is what i really like about it
as well um so
people people doing any of these events
i understand that we've got
some different certifications some some
sort of
recognition that people can get for
completing different things so can you
explain just a little bit about that
sure well and absolutely and we were
talking about boot camp and one of the
um outcomes of our boot camp was that
campers
uh received a certificate of program
completion
uh for you know just attending and
participating in the boot camp
but then we have a level we have level
one and level two certifications and
this is a
this is a newer initiative from wolfram
and
you can go to our certifications page
and you can see it's it's got a whole
range of different
categories topics types many of them
are related to our interactive courses
for instance the the multiple i can do
that right here and show you how that
looks
um this is what the course looks like
and so these are all different videos
different video lessons that play
there's a
lesson notebook on the side and then
this is even a
scratch notepad that you're live in the
wolfram language in the cloud and can
try out
many of these examples yourself from the
course
so um again our
certifications are tied to these courses
so when you complete
and i'll just kind of select data
science here when i complete
the data science course i can get a
certificate and it's all embedded in
that course
you don't have to ask anybody for
anything your your interactive course
tracks your progress for you as you
complete all those videos
and pass the quizzes within that course
you earn your course
certificate we have additional
uh certification levels beyond that
course completion
and that's a level one and here i'm
showing you our wolfram language and
mathematica level one certifications
these are based on a an exam so these
are not tied to a particular course
but once you feel like you have um
there's some guy a process here that's
recommended
once you feel like you have explored
a lot of the different areas of the
language and of course there's a there
are
there's a very vast language and a lot
of functionality so
you do want to kind of review what your
you know what this exam is going to
cover
but uh this again is a free exam and you
request the exam and if you pass it
you've earned your
wolfram technology level one
certification for the wolfram language
right so so that's sort of um level one
is a certification specifically for the
language
where i'm data science course uh so i
haven't haven't done
i don't think i've done the level one
certification yet though so maybe i
should get on that
right and we hope to expand this is a a
program that is
you know we have plans for additional
certifications in fact
level one um in image processing
level one in multi-paradigm
data science those will become available
within those courses
and as you'd expect they require kind of
an additional assessment piece
so you might be taking an exam you might
be taking
you might be doing some uh auto graded
exercises
within that cloud interface to
demonstrate
your competency in that particular area
using the
wolfram language but we do hope to have
level one
certifications i can show you right now
the ones we have right now are in
calculus and linear algebra
and these are both exam based kind of
you know how you'd expect a traditional
math course
uh to run to get your level one in
linear algebra you you
uh complete the final exam within this
course same thing with calculus
and um if you come to this page in the
near future and
uh view and browse these level one
certifications
you'll see image processing and data
science added to the list
in the very near future okay so there
will be topic specific ones there as
well
right right um yeah and you mentioned
that uh
it's sort of automated uh quizzes and
grading and things which is one of the
one of the interesting parts to me it's
kind of nice that you can get through
all of that process and learn so much
without necessarily having to have a
mentor or a teacher there to sort of
step you through each part of the
process exactly we don't require that's
why we can make it for free right now
there's no proctor there's no
uh individual grading your exam it's all
automatically done in the cloud which
and it's a very ambitious project
um and the technology required is
uh is one we're troubleshooting and um
that and it so it takes a while and i
know people are very anxious for us to
get more certifications up but
we want to do it right and we want it to
be uh to perform just the way we want it
to
when our customers access these
certifications
um and one more thing about
certification i might add brian if i can
is that level two
um is available with the multi-paradigm
data science
course and that's what we offer to those
uh
participants at bootcamp who were able
to uh
submit their final projects like the
ones you saw in the blog post there
and that is a paid certification because
it is actually a project that
one of our instructors grades so that's
a very personal assessment
and that's our highest certification
type right now is level two and that's
available
in the data science topic area that
makes sense so
so you get a little bit more of the the
personalized attention maybe you have to
do a little bit
uh more in depth of a project um but
it's
it's worth it because absolutely it's
quite a learning experience
right cool is there anything else that
you wanted to
uh talk about in reference to um
what what kinds of i guess where would
somebody
use these certifications oh well we hope
people will post them on
their profile pages like linkedin um we
have
a linkedin group set up now with wolfram
you
any place that you share professional
credentials on your cv
on your resume um again it's a it's a
newer program
but we are um we are looking forward to
seeing more and more people
take part and uh and and list those
certifications
and their credentials um and i i think
you might have mentioned
this um but people can get
certifications from
the daily study group as well is that is
that correct that's true
that's true yes and it does depend um
on the topic we have a variety of
different topics that we run through
these study groups but for instance
linear algebra is the one that's coming
next
you can earn a certificate of program
completion by attending and taking part
in that
study group you also need to take a
weekly quiz um
to demonstrate you know that you've been
there and you're involved
and that will earn you your certificate
of completion the level one
in linear algebra will continue to offer
through that course
so what we'll what we'll be telling
people in the study group is we're
working very closely with our linear
algebra interactive course
and we encourage them to then go
complete their level one
um by completing the requirements in
that course
which of course involves that final exam
if you remember so
some extra work for sure to get that
level one
all right well thank you very much for
uh
telling me all about that um so anyone
who's interested can definitely
just watch the wolf from you page for
upcoming events
um join the daily study group for linear
algebra which is coming up very soon and
hopefully people can
uh you know take the initiative get
their certifications and
really uh make the most out of what
we've gotten well from you so
thank you very much for talking to me
jamie thank you brian i appreciate it
thanks for joining us you can check out
other wolfram tech talks live coding
streams and more on the wolfram research
youtube channel
or see what else is new at wolfram.com